good morning john here in the u.s the
moment has arrived everyone over the age
of 16 can get a covered vaccine
over 200 million doses have been
administered and around 40
of people have gotten at least one dose
and yet
the graph of people getting vaccinated
every day it's starting to stop do
this it's like going higher every day
it's starting to go less and less every
day
and the reason for this is largely
younger people by which i mean people
under the age of 50
not getting their vaccine immediately it
could be that you watching this video
right now are one of those people or
maybe you know
some of those people and you want to
send them this video so i want to go
very quickly through a few of the
reasons why i've heard young people
specifically say
they haven't gotten vaccinated yet and
first i think tremendously underexamined
is just that like it's a slightly
unpleasant task that i don't want to add
to my list of things to do and since now
you can do it at any time people are
putting it off
schedules are busy and you know that the
day after your second dose you might
feel pretty crummy i certainly did so
why not put it off to a more convenient
time but as with all procrastinations
look there's not really a better time
than now but you also gotta look at what
the trade-off here is
like we're dealing with like mild
inconvenience that is scheduled
versus unscheduled major inconvenience
and maybe worse the symptoms of kovid
suck no matter how old you are kova does
kill young people just doesn't kill very
many of them but hospitalization rates
are pretty high and spending a bunch of
time in the hospital is so
bad it's also like a burden on
healthcare workers who are
overburdened enough right now there are
also a bunch of long-term side effects
from getting covered that we don't
understand super well right now and
those sometimes even happen when people
get very mild cases but even if you get
none of that
it's still like really inconvenient to
get covered you feel like crap
you have to quarantine it's inconvenient
for you
and everyone else in your world so why
not decrease the odds of that happening
by 95
but maybe you're not worried about
yourself at all it's still really
important to recognize that every person
except like the first person who gets
coveted gets it from somebody else and
it's very easy to not
know when you are the person who got
someone sick because a lot of people
get sick by being exposed to people who
are infected
but don't even know that they are if
you're vaccinated the odds of you
getting another person
sick go way way way down
and then much more unlikely but even
scarier
every one of the new coveted variants
that we're talking about right now
every one of them evolved inside of a
person
and we will never know who that person
was but i think that we all
can agree that like we don't want to be
that person nobody wants to be the
breeding ground from which a new variant
of covet emerges you can prevent
yourself from being that person
by getting a vaccine and finally i've
also heard some people saying
you know i got kovid or i think i got
kovid or i might as well just get kovid
and i can get immunity that way leaving
aside the fact that it is a big deal and
you might infect someone who for whom it
will be an even bigger deal immunity
from getting kovid
is much less effective at preventing
future covet infections
than the vaccines are so if you've had
covet or you think you might have
or you think i'll just get it and then
i'll be immune that way none of that
works
you need a vaccine i understand that
every person is experiencing this
differently
and also that it's frustrating and
annoying like this thing
has been in charge of our lives for too
long and for many people
a vaccine feels like a way of taking
back control
while for others it feels like more
control that they're giving up for me
it felt like taking back control i think
to some extent
because the vaccines are a really big
deal and they are such a triumph of
hard work and human ingenuity that it's
easy to think like
i have to think really hard about this
it's something to worry about and to
fret over
but my friends it's really not the
decision here is simple it is both
a big deal but also like not a big deal
like it's just not a big deal so if you
need one final reason to go get a
vaccine
hi i'm hank green i make science videos
i've been making educational videos for
people for free on the internet for
over 10 years and maybe you want to do
me a favor it's super easy there's a
link in the description you can click on
it put in your zip code and make your
appointment for getting your covered
vaccine put it in your phone
then go do it and get a free doughnut
john i'll see you on tuesday